mean physical prowess is something and
it's not nothing that physical
confidence that comes along with that as
well but the same thing replicated at
the level of the ability to communicate
and to think that's way broader field of
battle and opportunity this is one thing
that isn't taught well especially to
boys there's nothing that makes you more
formidable than verbal competence and
being able to articulate be able to
think to Marshal your arguments right
it's a battlefield metaphor get
everything in order all your information
straight you know to Marshall your
forces I mean that's part of the reason
that rap artists are so popular
especially among disaffected young men
black and white light because they're
unbelievably articulate they have this
incredible verbal prowess it's
unbelievably attractive you know and
it's associated with genuine artistic
and Redemptive activity often focusing
on something that's approximately the
voice of the underclass let's say it's
interesting to see how many young white
guys identify with that hey Tevin
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Jordan Peterson enjoy
the Elder sexy that wrote doors of
perception yeah yeah so this is kind of
an equivalent of that right that you
have a experience which many people
struggle to articulate you take the best
of us
the one that has the most precise most
articulate erudite language you drop
them in and you say okay
show us what you've learned this is the
equivalent but for just a different
Community a different sort of life that
maybe you don't have the ability to
describe what it feels like to live on a
council estate in Manchester or in you
know the one of the neighborhoods of
Brooklyn or whatever it might be
and then this person can and it feels
like it's your voice yeah well you still
if you're a young man you still feel
alienated from your place as rightful
error of the proper Kingdom I mean
that's an existential truism for
everyone for every particularly for
every young man because he is an
outsider in many ways he's young and
juvenile and not very highly valued and
and then is is in some sense hurt by the
inadequacies of the current King the
current culture and and is easily turned
against it because of that and that's
the machinations of the evil Uncle
that's the King Arthur story that's the
story of Horus Horus and Osiris it's an
Ancient Ancient story it's the story of
Sauron and
um
it's there all the time and
you see in that in rap music in hip-hop
the the all of that alienation being
given an articulated voice in in an
artistic sense and that's a good example
of the power of verbal facility and
that's the route to let's say marketing
education to young man it's like you
wanna you wanna take your rightful place
in the Kingdom it's like get your tongue
straight man get it under control
in the highest possible sense we went to
a comedy club Tammy and I and
in New York the comedy seller it's a
great comedy club and the last Comic was
an English guy and uh he was not
particularly physically pre-possessing
and he he made a lot of jokes about that
and it was quite funny and then he
divided the audience into five sections
and he asked each section to toss up a
topic just to Yellow the topic and they
were like random topics like the Kennedy
assassination and electric lighting
before 1890 those were two of the topics
and the other three were just as diverse
and then he put on some beats and he did
about an eight minute wrap
with every verse rhymed
and he tied the whole thing together at
the end and ended at the end of the
music all spontaneously it was
unbelievable and that's logos man that's
the Redemptive power of the logos right
there the magic word the sacred word
it's just manifesting itself on stage
this is very impressive something about
that that does feel dangerous as well
and not in a I need to be concerned and
this should be contaminated and walled
off but in a way that you think that
person has so much competence that it
it's flowing out of them and you almost
feel competent by being around them so
but you certainly feel confident by
appreciating it right because it speaks
to the part of you that is capable of
appreciating such things you think wow
that's really something that's really
that's an amazing display that's an
amazing thing to see amazing right a
very interesting word amazing and you're
you're trapped and you're trapped by the
Charisma of that and that Charisma
that's not nothing that's that's a
signal of something Redemptive occurring
that that accounts for
virtually all of the attraction of
hip-hop and rap
it's the articulate articulated voice of
the struggling
but Worthy
underclass I suppose that's a good way
of putting it but those who are
alienated from their rightful place
and so that verbal prowess is one of the
ways they
struggle up towards the light you know
and and that that's a good example of
that uh
of having that danger under control
because it's a dark genre in many ways
right it's it's a there's a there's a
there's a real undercurrent an air of
violence that surrounds that and its
culture like the punk movement in the in
in in the UK back in the late 70s same
same sort of thing
but that
that capacity to express that in a
poetic manner in a compelling manner Sid
or Johnny rodden was great at that is so
intense his he worked with pil
afterwards Public Public Image Limited
is that his Public Image I think so he
has a song called rise which I used to
show my my clients all the time when I
was starting uh uh assertiveness
training with them I'd put on Johnny
rotten's rise and the line in there is
anger is an energy and he's got these
unbelievably intense eyes anger is an
energy you bet and John Lyden man he
could channel that like almost no one
I've ever seen he'd get that anger built
up inside him and then it was completely
under control and he expressed it in his
music and he's absolutely captivating
unbelievably charismatic and I really
like this music that raw anger in the
music that but it was it was in the
bloody music wasn't it
wasn't some random riot you know he
transmuted that into something you know
you can argue about the poetic merits of
um
of punk rock although I don't think you
should I mean uh
I Did It My Way Sid vicious's version of
it I did it my way my God that's a work
of Genius that it's so it's so
brilliantly satirical rule number two is
pursue your goals we know enough about
psychology now to know that almost all
of the positive emotion that you're
going to experience in your life and
positive emotion is analgesic by the way
right it actually quells pain so it's
not just positive it also gets rid of
negative which is a big plus almost all
the positive emotion that you're going
to feel you're going to feel in
relationship to a goal because you feel
positive emotion as you approach a goal
and so if you want to feel positive
emotion then you need a goal and then
you might think well if you want to
maximize that positive emotion which is
enthusiasm and also what pulls you out
into the world as well as feeling good
then you need the best possible goal
well that because that's going to engage
them largest
segments of your being like if your goal
is too narrow then a bunch of you isn't
going to be on board for it you know if
the goal is well developed and
multifaceted then all of you can partake
in that even your negative elements even
your anger and and your fear can get on
board with that let's say so you need a
goal man that's worthy you've got to
think you're good you need a goal that
justifies the tragedy and malevolence of
life that seems to be the bottom line
now maybe you think well there's no gold
that can do that it's like well
there are still better and worse goals
so and I'm not convinced that there are
no goals that can do that I think that's
an open question
you'd never know that until you pursued
the proper goal long enough to find out
who you would be
as a consequence of pursuing it so
that's also your destiny or your
existential Voyage right it's also not
something that anyone else can do for
you someone can say get your act
together for Christ's sake and get it
get get at it that's that'll make the
world unfold best for you but there's no
way you can know that without doing it
so
and unless you think you've done a
particularly Stellar job of that then
you have no reason to doubt its
potential validity
so plus like crickets are telling you
this and so
you know they're a very reliable source
okay so you see the star the star recurs
as a motif in Pinocchio and one of the
more interesting elements of it here is
that when Geppetto wants to transform
his puppet the marionette who's being
played by forces that operate behind the
scenes which is a really good definition
of the Persona from a union perspective
right and also something indicative of
something like an ideological or
conceptual possession
Geppetto who's a good guy he's a
positive father figure
lifts his even though he's a patriarchal
figure right and a very competent one he
still even lifts his eyes up to
something that transcends his motive
being positive as it is and wishes that
his creation would undertake the kind of
transformation that would make it
autonomous and fully functional as a
moral agent no strings right so that's
very interesting I think
said the salvation of mankind lies only
in making everything the concern of all
that's a pretty decent star-like goal I
would say
and so what happens in the Pinocchio
story is that because and I think this
is a symbolic representative of what I
just described to you that happens at a
genetic level if you put yourself in new
situations so
Geppetto is roughly culture in the
Pinocchio story right he's he's a
Craftsman he's he's a and and he makes
Pinocchio so he's he's
who's his son he's the socializing agent
and
he aims for something above mere
socialization which is I think part of
the mysterious element of human beings
you know in our scientific models we
basically have socialization and biology
but there's always a third element
mythological stories which is whatever
you might construe as the spontaneous
action of Consciousness that's
associated with free will and you know
that's just basically being
conceptualized in religious terms as
something akin to the soul now we don't
have a category for that scientifically
because what we try to do scientifically
is to reduce everything either to
socialization or to biology
but it isn't clear to me that that's
it's perfectly reasonable from the
perspective of practicality at a
scientific level you don't want to
multiply explanatory principles Beyond
necessity but there's many things that
that doesn't come to terms with such as
the fact that we all treat each other as
autonomous beings with Free Will and
that that seems to work and that if we
stop doing that then things go to hell
very very rapidly so and the mere fact
that we have been able to conceptualize
what that conscious Free Will might be
metaphysically or physically doesn't
mean it doesn't exist it just means that
we don't understand it I mean what it
was only in the last 15 years that we
discovered that 95 of the universe was
made out of some kind of matter that we
can't even
whose properties we can't even imagine
except that it seems to have mass
so
anyways what happens is when Geppetto
reach lifts his eyes up to the star
he so it's Society aligning itself with
the proper goal with regards to
individual development right so so there
instead of society being at odds with
the individual they line up and then
what happens is nature comes on board
and that's the Blue Fairy in the in the
Pinocchio story and that's seems to me
to be a symbolic representation of what
happens biologically when when you set
the goal properly get your culture
behind you and move into the world is
that
there's a biological transformation that
occurs as a consequence of that which
means that a bunch of you that hasn't
been turned on turns on
and I guess one question would be is
what would you be like if you turned on
everything inside of you that could be
turned on
well that's a good goal that's a good
thing to find out
so
now
I'm going to introduce a couple of other
ideas so
there's this idea in jungian Psychology
called the circumambulation and Jung had
this idea that you had a potential
future self which would be in potential
everything that you could be and that it
manifests itself moment to moment in
your present Life by making you
interested in things and the things that
you're interested in are the things that
would guide you along the path that
would lead you to maximal development
now it sounds like a metaphysical idea
or a or a mystical idea even but but
it's not it's it's not it's a really
profoundly biological idea the idea is
something like well
you're set up so that you're
automatically interested in those things
that with fully expand you as a
well-adapted creature well like there's
nothing radical about that idea how well
what else could possibly be the case
unless there's something fundamentally
flawed about you that is what the
situation would be it's kind of
interesting to think about how that
would be manifest moment to moment but
the idea is something like well your
interest is captured by those things
that lead you down the path of
development
well that better be the case Okay so
that's fine and so there's some utility
in pursuing those things that you're
interested in that's the Call to
Adventure let's say
so and the call to adventure takes you
all sorts of places now the problem with
the Call to Adventure is like what the
hell do you know
you might be interested in things that
are kind of warped and bent
and often it's the case that when new
parts of people manifest themselves and
grip their interests say they do it very
badly and shortly
and so you stumble around like an idiot
when you try to do something new that's
why the fool is the precursor to the
Savior from the from the symbolic
perspectives because you have to be a
fool before you can be a master and if
you're not willing to be a fool then you
can't be a master so
so you're gonna it's an error error
written process and that's also laid out
in the Old Testament stories because the
first thing that happens to all these
patriarchal figures when God kicks them
out of their father's house when they're
like 84 is that they they run into all
sorts of trouble and some of it's social
and some of it's natural and some of
it's a consequence of their own moral
inadequacy so they're fools and but but
the thing that's so interesting is that
despite the fact that they're fools
they're still supposed to go on the
adventure and that they're capable of
learning enough as a consequence of
moving forward on the adventure so that
they straighten themselves out across
time
and so it's something like this this
circumambulation that Jung talked about
was this continual we'll return to this
this continual circling in some sense of
who you could be you might notice for
example that there are themes in your
life you know when you go back across
your experiences you see you kind of
have your typical experience that sort
of repeats itself and there might be
variation on it like a musical theme but
it's it's like you're circling yourself
and getting closer to yourself as you
move across time that's the
circumambulation now you remember that
for a sec because we'll go back to it
okay so imagine that something glimmers
before you it's an interest that's
Dawning and you decide well first of all
you're paralyzed you think well how do I
know if I should pursue that it's
probably a stupid idea and the proper
response to that is you're right it
probably is a stupid idea because almost
all all ideas are stupid and so the the
probability that as you move forward on
your adventure that you're going to get
it right the first time is zero it's
just not going to happen and so then you
might think well maybe I'll just wait
around until I get the right idea and
which people do right so they're like 40
year old 13 year olds which is not a
good idea so they wait around until it's
waiting for Godot until they finally got
it right but the problem is you're too
stupid to know when you've got it right
so waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so so you
have there's Nitric called that a will
to stupidity which I really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it you know it's it's you have to take
it into account fundamentally and work
with it and so and so you can take these
tentative steps on your pathway to
Destiny and you can assume that you're
going to do it badly and that's really
useful because you don't have to beat
yourself up it's pretty easy to do it
badly but the thing is it's way better
to do it badly than not to do it at all
and that's the continual message that
Echoes through these historical stories
in Genesis it's like these are flawed
people they they should have got the
hell out of their house way before they
did
um and they go out and they stumble
around in tyranny and famine and
self-betrayal and and
violence and but it's a hell of a lot
better than just rotting away at home
rule number three slay the dragon I can
tell why
the dragon Hoards treasure everywhere
the dragon is an amalgam of predatory
stimuli and Fire
which is a destructive force but also
very useful so dragon is something like
predatory destructive entity you might
say well is that real it's like well
yeah but it's a meta category it's like
there are lions and Raptors and
um lizards let's say uh 60 million years
ago when we were still in trees
the idea that there's a meta Predator is
a great idea a meta Predator is what all
predators share in common
that's a dragon well what should you do
with a dragon
well avoid it that's one answer another
answer is burn it out of its layer so
that it doesn't have baby dragons the
and the uh an even more sophisticated
answer is well
confront it
you can feed your family with the body
of a dragon
it's treasure
and then that's become abstracted up
into the unknown as such
you do a great job of uh telling the
story of Tiamat mardic all of that in a
way where you re-grounded it in the
actual historical context because they
talk about when you slay the dragon you
can actually build things from it they
talk about the from its pieces right
having an earthquake it's amazing I
thought wow it's kind of interesting and
then you said no no they actually used
to build the you know the doorways to
their cave or whatever from the bones of
the animals that they slayed and I
thought oh my god when you put the story
in that context of you're telling the
tribe something that they're actually
doing but you're elevating it and so
you're saying look the Great Hero goes
and slays the most dangerous of the most
dangerous predatory thing and from that
we're not just creating our house we're
creating the Heaven and the Earth and I
thought whoa like you really do so I'm
gonna that's why in Christianity which
is it has taken the hero myth in in a
tremendously sophisticated Direction
Christ
tackles the worst of all potential
dragons and that's the adversary that's
the evil in the human heart
it's become completely psychologized by
that point or spiritualized instead of
an external monster that's the threat
and let's make no mistake external
monsters are are threatening
but then there's direct external
monsters that are other tribes
well those are genuinely threatening too
and we can demonize
a member of another tribe at the drop of
a hat
but then you take one level above that
even you think well the most dangerous
thing of all is the evil that lurks in
the human heart
in the individual
and that's why you have the battle let's
say between Christ and Satan that's what
that means it's not all it means
but that's what it means and and so what
you and then you ask yourself like you
can ask yourself this question very
seriously
if you were thinking about the most
moral possible action
wouldn't that be
the voluntary constraint of the evil
that you yourself are likely to do
and wouldn't that mean facing human evil
in its reality as it manifests itself
inside you and wouldn't that mean then
obtaining victory over that
and you might say well is that a Divine
story well
it's the it
I can't say what the relationship is
between the human psyche and and the
world as such
but we don't have a deeper story than
that
and I can't see how it's not true and
you might say well it's not true for me
it's like well don't you have a
conscience
doesn't it bother you
and then can you control it an answer to
that is almost inevitably no it calls
you to account
and why well because you've deviated
from the ideal who's ideal
an ideal that's making itself known
within you at least in so far as the
objection arises you wake up at three in
the morning and torture yourself for
your iniquities
and you would think well I could just
shut that off it's me after all but you
can't shut it off you're nothing
compared to your conscience
no it's strange because you can ignore
it you cannot live according to its
dictates but it's not going to leave you
alone
Jordan you asked the times person uh in
the full-length article or full-length
recording which I listened to you said
hey don't focus on my illness in this
focus on why people resonate with my
message which she of course did not uh
but that leaves no one does oh it leaves
me an opening I'm gonna take it right
now it's so interesting to see that is
that
it's so interesting because
you know the only time that ever gets
addressed is by the mainstream media
Jesus you know a horrible cliche but
it's usually sort of brushed off and
it's usually well he seems to be
attractive towards young men who are
troubled
well first of all that's not so bad is
it I mean hypothetically the most Ardent
feminist is primarily concerned with
helping the troubled young man not be so
troubled
but it's brushed off in a cynical sort
of way and it the cynicism is also
disbelief that that could possibly be
serious
a serious Enterprise well I think it's a
serious Enterprise
I think it's because
who knows the final answer to anything
you know but I took what I learned about
what happened in the second world war
seriously
it's like wow we can be really bad
we should do something about that
like that was unacceptable
what was it or not but how unacceptable
was it change your life unacceptable
better be
if you want it not to happen again
and it's not like it the next time it
happens
will make the previous time look like a
picnic
we're way more powerful than we were
you know when we're getting to the point
of something Jung talked about
especially near the end of his life
we're getting so powerful that each
individual is now a force of almost
unimaginable destructive power if they
so choose to be
and that's just going to
that power is going to continue to
increase
and what that means is that the degree
to which each of us has our act together
is going to be something upon which the
world increasingly Depends for its
maintenance also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four aim for sustainable
Improvement Alan Watts has this quote
where he says we can become so consumed
with trying to improve our lives that we
all together forget to live them is
there a way that people can learn to let
go of this compulsion a little bit
that's a really good question
um
I think my my second book
implicitly answers some of that
and explicitly some of it as well but
the implicit part is there's an
increased emphasis on
social
ties
and so for me I
snap out of the Improvement slash
productivity trap to the degree that I'm
able
when I'm playing with my family let's
say when we're joking when we're sitting
around a meal time together when when
there's peace there and we can joke and
play and I'm trying as particularly as
I'm trying to regain my health I'm
trying to really rekindle that capacity
to play and enjoy the moment
even if I'm not doing something
is productive and there
that that's a very difficult balance to
attain optimally like any optimal
balance is difficult to attain
um you know it isn't obvious to me how
much of I have no idea
the the multiple sources of my health
troubles I was diagnosed this month with
severe sleep Central sleep apnea and so
that was a great relief because I have a
machine now so I breathe properly I was
waking up uh 25 times an hour apparently
my sleep was so I was getting no
restorative sleep
and so that was one contrib major
contributor and since I've been
breathing at night I've actually been
feeling quite a bit better
unsurprisingly
um
but I've been scouring my conscience to
determine if you have an undiagnosed
illness especially if it's severe it's
very likely that you're going to tear
yourself apart looking for what you did
wrong to have this arise
and you know I think that I
it so I've been considering did I take
on too much responsibility did I work
too much
etc etc
um I don't know the answer to that yet
but what I do know is that since I've
been trying to regain my health
I've been doing a lot of walking and
that's been really good and I'm not
working while I'm walking I'm walking
and I've been working out more and I've
been playing more and I've been dancing
more and that's all useful and that has
to be balanced with that productivity
because what you're looking for eh
you're looking for improvement but
you're looking for sustainable
Improvement
and so if you push yourself too hard you
you destroy the sustainability across
time
and and you want that sustainability
there so you can't push yourself any
farther than you're capable of going in
the long run I found for example because
I've written
diligently
for a long time daily and I learned
quite early on that
writing more than three hours a day was
counterproductive whatever I gained from
a four hour writing session I'd lose the
next day or two
so but I also think you have to kind of
push yourself past your limits before
you can retract to the optimal place and
that can't be sort of defined a priority
because each person's limit is different
and I think so I think what you do when
you're young in your 20s if you're
perhaps if you're
operating in a
optimal manner is you push yourself to
your limits and then
pull back and
adjust for sustainability and I help
lots of people do that in my clinical
practice like I work with
lawyers who who are at the Pinnacle of
their profession
and the demands on them are incredible
they're working 60 to 80 hours a week
um generally what I did with them was
get them to take more days off they
couldn't work shorter days but they
could plan four day weekends two months
in advance and they could do that every
two months then inevitably if they did
that the number of billable hours they
produced went up not down so they'd
maybe doubled their vacation time and
increase their productivity so it was a
really good deal for them they go up
their cake and eat it too they got to
have their cake and eat it too
so do we need to learn to play in a way
play can be uh we need to remember how
we all know right I mean we're play is
so deeply embedded in human beings it's
it's one of our primary modes of of of
cognition and adaptation mammals have a
specialized play circuit that's that's
that's that's it's biologically
what would you say specialized precisely
for play
and so and it's an interesting circuit
because
oh and a lot of this has been discovered
by people who study animal behavior
especially among rats but
play in rats produces prefrontal lobe
development and that's the highest
that's the part of the brain that's
responsible for highest order cognition
so rats have to play a lot to mature
properly and they play socially and
social play is social integration
there's no difference between the
ability to play socially and being
socially integrated
um like a good conversation at dinner
time is a form of play because there's
wit involved and there's banter and
there's timing and there's a dance and
there's you know there's the matching of
your physical responses to the physical
response of the other person it's it's
play but play is very easily inhibited
by almost any other motivational state
and so you can also tell that if you can
get yourself into a playful mood that
that you're in an optimal place
otherwise you wouldn't be able to do it
so it's a good sign that things are
going right rule number five be devoted
towards love Andrea asks a question
which I think a lot of people have
absolutely no framework for because we
live in an era of the collapse of
marriage in our society you know the
complete sort of breakdown of the family
unit unit that you were describing a
moment ago Dr Peterson and so Andrea
asks what is the secret to a healthy and
happy marriage I think that's it's
actually a very well
composed question a healthy and happy
marriage I actually don't think it's a
good question
[Laughter]
and I'll tell you I'll tell you why
I
think
happy is a pretty low goal
I mean first of all there's going to be
lots of times in your marriage
where you are seriously not happy
and sometimes that's going to be because
you're having conflict with your partner
but sometimes it's going to be because
all hell's broken loose around you and
then if if you judge the success of your
marriage on your happiness like and the
same thing happens if you judge your
success in life
on the basis of your happiness what do
you have when it's nothing but suffering
and that's going to be plenty of your
life
and so the whole orientation of that
question in that sense is wrong
what you want to have in your marriage
is I would say first of all first and
foremost uh like a scrupulous honesty
and I don't just mean that you tell each
other the truth because you can be
brutal with the truth I mean the kind of
honesty that's devoted towards thriving
in love you know and you want to act
nobly in your relationship you want to
be reliable and productive and generous
and and
and then if you're lucky
now and then
you might be happy and you might have a
clear enough conscience so that in those
rare moments where you are truly happy
you can also enjoy it without guilt
and so you aim at something a lot higher
than happiness
and then you welcome it if it deigns to
land on you for brief moments of time
rule number six turn chaos into order
how do you frame that how do you take
that emergent chaos and make habitable
order out of it you don't know is the
whole capitalist system rotten to the
core I mean that's a convenient
explanation under those circumstances
that's for sure were you working for a
psychopathic son of a [ __ ] did you make
the wrong choice in University and was
that your father's fault because you
never did what you want or was it your
fault for not standing up to him or is
it a dying industry or is maybe this a
wake-up call that you should go do
something else that you've been waiting
to do you know that you've actually
wanted to do your whole life and that's
why you're doing such a miserable job at
your current occupation because you're
bitter and resentful about the fact that
you never did what you want you don't
know it's all of those things at once
and that's very stressful because all of
those things at once is too many things
and that's the re-emergence of chaos
that's the flood
that's the return to the beginning of
the cosmos that's another way that it's
been represented mythologically it's
that you Voyage all the way back to the
beginning of the cosmos when there's
nothing but undifferentiated chaos and
that's what you're confronting and maybe
it's too much for you and often it is I
mean that that can really that can be
traumatizing it can hurt your brain you
know it's just too much for you to Bear
but it doesn't matter you're stuck with
it and so how do you respond to that
well some of it is catastrophic negative
emotion you freeze and that's protective
and maybe you don't even want to move
you don't want to bloody well get out of
bed for a week and that's because your
body is reacting as if the bedroom floor
is covered with snakes and the best
thing for you to do is just not move
just freeze not a pleasant situation to
be in because it's your hyper aroused
very very physiologically demanding and
there's zero about it that's productive
except maybe the snakes won't see you
but they've already seen you so that
isn't helping very well so you've got
all this undifferentiated negative
emotion anxiety fear hurt anger guilt
shame emotional pain the whole plethora
of catastrophes and then maybe on the
other side lurking down there is thank
God I'm done with that job I just bloody
well hate it I drag myself off to work
every day and there's a little part of
my soul that's so goddamn happy I
finally got fired that I can hardly
stand it you know and maybe you don't
even admit that to yourself because well
that would mean that all that time you
spent at the job was just sunk cost
you're diluting yourself the whole time
um it is an interesting thing to
consider though sometimes if you're in
the unpleasant circumstance of having to
fire someone you know sometimes firing
someone is the best thing that can
happen to them which doesn't mean that
you should go out and like enjoy it
although I have met very disagreeable
people who actually enjoyed firing
people I'll tell you a story about that
at some point because it's quite
interesting but you know sometimes if
someone's just limping along in their
job and doing it as miserably and
wretchedly as they possibly can imagine
the best thing you can do to them for
them is to say you know
you're failing at this and and that
doesn't necessarily mean that you would
have to be failing at absolutely
everything else in the entire world so
maybe you should just accept the damn
failure and go off and try something new
and I mean that's terrifying for people
and I know they hate it and all that but
but
sometimes it's better than the
alternative which is just slow torturous
death
so
here's a funny way of looking at it
so let's say you fall right into that
hole that's underneath any everything
and you've hit an anomaly that you don't
understand you say what's that anomaly
made out of exactly I know that's a
strange way of thinking about it you
know because it's not
well you could say
we'll just go along with that it's a
metaphor what's that anomaly made out of
well here's a way of thinking about it's
made out of Spirited matter
and here's why
this is something I learned in part from
Piaget said
well it's made out of matter because of
course that's the world matter and the
world is also what matters and so that's
kind of a nice Duality there but it's
made out of spirit because when you
encounter something anomalous and go
down the rabbit hole when you go into
the underworld it's underneath
everything that you've relied on
you learn things down there so what's
down there is information
and that now it's maybe way more
information than you want but it is
information it's information and what
can what can you do with the information
you can inform yourself with the
information right you can put yourself
in formation with the information that's
helpful too
and so and you think well you you're a
psyche maybe you're not a spirit it
depends on you know whether you're a
materialist or not but at least we can
say that you're a psyche the question is
what's your psyche made of well it's
obviously got a material substrate but
the matter happens to be a raid in a
particular order and that's an
information order and so when you fall
into the underworld it's underneath
everything and you encounter that latent
information then what you can do is
enhance your psyche you can grow your
spirit because what you do is you take
the new information and you incorporate
it that's like eating the Apple that
Adam and Eve you incorporate that and
that makes more of you and that's not a
metaphorical or a metaphysical
proposition it's not it's to say nothing
other than well that's what happens when
children learn you say think of what
happens Charles 3 has a pretty low
resolution representation of the world
and is a fairly low resolution human
being got all the constituent elements
there but isn't differentiated in any
tremendous manner that's all still to
come in the future and so what does the
child do explore what do they explore
things they don't understand that's
where the information is because you
already understand what you understand
there's no information there you go
where they're where you don't understand
that's where the information is and out
of that information you generate a
higher resolution world and you generate
a higher resolution self and so out of
the combat with the underlying Dragon of
chaos you generate spirit and matter and
that's what you do when you go down into
the underworld
so if it doesn't kill you
or if it doesn't make you wish you were
dead which it probably will but there's
a bunch of you that has to die down
there anyway so maybe that's not such a
bad thing because if you had this
relationship that ended in betrayal then
there's something that's just not
exactly right right there's something
that went and the reason I'm saying that
you think well that's kind of moralistic
it's like actually I don't mind being
moralistic in case you haven't noticed
but
but that's not it's not a fair comment
because you're playing the stupid game
it's like you live with someone
infidelity that's the game right you've
decided the rules with the game comes
immorality the morality are the rules of
the game well then the thing collapses
into infidelity it's like well you
played the game wrong or it was the
wrong game one of those two it's one of
those two you pick the damn game and
having picked the game you can't all of
a sudden say well no those aren't the
rules it's like yeah yeah if you pick
the game you pick the rules and if you
fail at complying with the rules then
you failed now you could say well I
could pick a different game it's like I
don't care how you solve the problem
you're still stuck with the problem it's
a moral problem fundamentally
and it might take some major league
retooling too
to fix it
so you're at Point a trying to get to
point B that's not working out you hit
an anomaly
you're not getting to point B that's for
sure
your medical school student you write
your mcats which is this test you have
to write to go to medical school you get
25th percentile I don't know who you are
but you're not a pre-med student and
maybe you never were right and that's
the rub man and so who the hell are you
you don't know collapse down here into
this motivational conflict this place of
motivational and emotional uncertainty
and tremendous information right it's a
place of transformation it's the Phoenix
that burns it's the burning part of the
Phoenix that burns it's it's the journey
to the underworld it's the journey to
hell it can really be a journey to hell
because you may find out that the reason
that your partner betrayed you or that
you didn't get your damn promotions
because there is seriously something
wrong with you and you know it and I
don't just mean that you don't know what
you're doing I mean that there's 25
percent of you that is seriously aiming
at things not being good and so you fall
into the underworld and you find out
that oh
God I just got exactly what I was aiming
for or I got exactly what the worst part
of me was aiming for and that worst part
that's something to clean up and that's
not going to be easy because it's got
its hooks in me like something something
ferocious something seriously ferocious
and I've been toying with it for a very
long time and maybe I can't even detach
it anymore and so that's not so fun and
you see people like that in
Psychotherapy very frequently or you see
them wandering around on the streets
like the absolute catastrophic former
shells of themselves you know because
they've hit the underworld and they
ended up in hell and there's no getting
out of it and so those are the people
you tend to give a wide birth to when
you walk down the street animal number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is heal your trauma
you mentioned sexual shame
um and it triggered something in me
about just the shames of the past that
people tend to hold on to I think I
might have mentioned this to you the
last time we talked I'm not sure if if
you know but I was I was sexually abused
when I was five by a man that I didn't
know and for 25 years I held on to the
secret the shame and if anyone ever knew
about this then I would never be loved I
you know right because you feel
contaminated permanently yeah I would
you know I wouldn't have any guy friends
no girls would find me attractive my
parents would disown me you know I went
down the rabbit hole of these stories of
you know I'm the only one this has ever
happened to I'd never saw any examples
of this happening too right and about
eight years ago I started to really heal
that and start sharing that shame in
many different
therapeutic experiences that allowed me
to start the healing process I'm curious
from your perspective with all the work
that you've done
what is the best approach for someone to
really heal their shame if whether it's
around sexual abuse or trauma or just
anything whether it be small or big or
any type of shame that they might have
how does someone release shame
in a healthy manner so that it doesn't
make them a prisoner of these emotions
of the past that hold them back
well you hinted at a few things when you
just described what what happened to you
is you said well first of all
you know I thought I was the only person
this had ever happened to
it's like no it's a universal
Human Experience
to one degree or another now you know
I'm not saying everyone was sexually
abused and I'm certainly not saying that
some people
aren't sexually abused to a degree
that's so extreme it's unimaginable
where are there others you know get off
relatively lightly but it's still it's
it's well within the realm of normative
Human Experience
that sexual
that sex goes wrong in some way at least
you regret something that's happened
something you've done or something that
was done to you
so the putting it in to when when you're
the only person that something has
happened to that's really not good right
because it alienates you even from
yourself you have no idea what to do
with that and so that's sometimes why
people find it such a relief to have
their illness diagnosed
it's like oh
there is this is known
there's a category other people have had
this experience maybe there's a pathway
through it so just knowing that you're
not the only person like that can be
very helpful
um
updating it's like how you were how old
five okay well one thing to realize when
you're 25
and you were abused when you're five is
that you're not five anymore right right
that the person to whom that happened is
no longer there you're there but so you
know you might feel afraid of
relationships you might feel afraid of
all sorts of things but a lot of that
was you're sort of feeling that like
that residual five-year-old
I tell a story about one client I had
she was abused by her older brother and
she told me this story and I drew a
picture in my head while she was you
know I kind of pictured her of at five
and this teenage hulking teenager you
know taking advantage of her but as she
told the story I realized that her older
brother was only
a year two years older than her well he
was seven was like okay well they were
she wasn't the victim of a tyrannical
male in some sense she they were too
badly supervised children now that
doesn't mean that what he did was right
but she was still the five-year-old in
the memory but she was 27 when or so
when she came to see me and so the first
thing I did was just point that out it's
like think about the seven-year-olds you
know hmm
right from for a five-year-old a
seven-year-old is an adult but for an
adult a seven and a five-year-old are
clearly both children well that just
changed things somewhat it made her feel
less vulnerable in the moment
what your brain wants from you in
relationship to a traumatic memory is
indication that you're no longer
vulnerable to the same problem that's
what memory is for right you remember
something bad and you process it so that
you change your interpretation or your
behavior or the situation or whatever
you can change so that it isn't going to
happen in the future and that'll if you
do that thoroughly you'll generally let
yourself rest
do you have the memory to protect
yourself from it happening again well
that's the purpose of memory in general
you you you make sense of your past
Behavior so that bet the good things
that happen to you can be duplicated and
the bad things can be avoided it's not
to make an objective record of the world
it's to make a functional map of the
world that you can apply to the Future
and so yeah how do we let that go how do
we disassociate something that happened
a year ago 10 20 years ago that is no
longer happening but it seems to be
triggering us oh it's very it's it's
very difficult well I would say you know
one of the things you need to develop if
you've had an experience like the one
you had perhaps because I don't know the
details you probably need a theory of
malevolence
you need an explanation it's like how
could a person do that
well you have to have an what if the
explanation isn't good they were just
bad person they just well then you need
a philosophy of bad you need a
philosophy of evil
you have to understand it so that you're
no longer a victim of it uh
you have because otherwise you can't put
the event in a context right you know
and sometimes that means the development
of real a real philosophical
sophistication
and that can help because then you know
then you can start to separate out
malevolence from benevolence because
maybe you're afraid of any intimate
relationship now because it's been
contaminated with that and everything's
fuzzy and foggy
and so you need to understand the person
who did that at least to some degree so
that you can separate that person out
from all the other people around you who
that you encounter in situations that
might be reminiscent of it you know so
you you felt vulnerable for out for
perhaps you felt ashamed all those
things have to be gone through what do
you think you know when you're ashamed
when does what elicits that what are the
eliciting cues what do you think when
that happens all of that has to be taken
apart I said in this Beyond order book
that you know if you have a memory older
than about 18 months that still bothers
you
right it's still got emotional resonance
older than 18 months ago or yeah no
older than 18 months ago or more
otherwise it's not really in the past
right it's still happening that that
whether you should delve into something
how you should delve into something
traumatic that's currently happening is
a whole different issue but if it's an
old memory and it still bothers you it
means that
you haven't
decompose that experience sufficiently
to detach it from the emo emotion so
imagine
when something terrible happens to you
you don't understand it
so then you might say well if you don't
understand something that's happening to
you how can it be terrible because
doesn't terrible mean that you
understand it
and the the answer is well you
understand things in stages
and the first way you understand the
terrible thing is by freezing in Terror
or running
that's the understanding
it's not conceptual it's embodied and
emotional
and so
event Terror that's the first category
okay now the next question is how do you
get it out how do you get out of the
terror
well
you realize that nothing truly dangerous
is happening well what if something
truly dangerous did happen
then you elaborate your view of the
world to the point where you're no
longer vulnerable to that terrible thing
you speak about the concept of the Soul
um do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
Soul
you know there's there's I would say
what we mean by soul is something like
animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well that's actually rather easy to
answer so when a child of four is
playing house
let's say what a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
Perceptions in the game what she
observed her mother literally doing so
for example she didn't go into her
mother's bedroom when her mother awoke
and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blanks so that she could mimic
that in her play and you know you think
that's absurd but it's not absurd if
it's just mimicry it's not it's
unbelievably sophisticated so what the
girl does is she watches her mother
manifest maternal Behavior across a vast
array of instances and she integrates
that with the image of the mother she's
received from all the books she's been
read and all the little movies she's
watched the Disney movies and so forth
and she abstracts out the animating
principle of the maternal and then she
embodies that in play and usually with a
little boy and that's practice for
what's going to come later it's
unbelievably sophisticated and she's
embodying a spirit and the spirit there
is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifest station and
if you think children can't do that well
then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that Spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know I had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
the mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way that would
unite the acts of benevolence across a
series of men that's all comprehensible
to you that's you take that as a matter
of course when you say that there are
such things as good men and you can
identify them right something stable
about whatever is good across multiple
manifestations of of incarnation let's
say and I saw that transform into the
the father person of the Trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent Spirit now
I don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but but
that
that Spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people I mean it's
part of what gives someone Charisma it's
part of what elicits the instinct to
imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something incredibly athletic
to put the goal to put the soccer ball
the football ball through the net to
score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
Divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of the
depth and utility of that response you
see this in all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated the soul is participating
in that in the fullest extent and you
know you can say well there's no use for
the religious there's no necessary use
for the religious terminologies like
well until you come up with a better
word there's plenty of use for it
because it's a very complex and deep
phenomena and to you know just
casted into the realm of superstition in
some casual manner is it's just not
helpful not in any possible it's not
helpful scientifically it's not helpful
ethically it's not helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really I mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief
really act it out you'll be like the
most hated person in town in about 15
minutes well I mean what do you make of
practical evidence like that I mean you
interact with people as if their free
Souls capable of choosing between good
and evil that's what you do all the time
and maybe you can Addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're kind
of a gabbling fool and it's just going
to make you trip over things you don't
even notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me I don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what I just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that Divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are Guided by love and your
words are Guided by truth you need that
instinct for meaning too so and we
should get this real straight why do you
need it
well you need it because life is really
really difficult right I mean people
have a rough time of it there's plenty
of suffering in life and everyone is
going to encounter it right there you
don't you know you learn this as a
clinical psychologist and you know this
generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long and and really talk to them
and get beneath the surface until you
find you know there's a tragedy or two
or three or ten lurking not very far
beneath the surface someone in the
family is very ill there's a childhood
history of extreme pathology alcoholism
somewhere in the family maybe a touch of
insanity someone has cancer you know
someone someone older relative is dying
there's financial trouble there's
economic trouble there's marital trouble
it's like life is trouble and now you
know that doesn't mean it's all trouble
but man it's trouble and sometimes it's
it's a lot of trouble and sometimes it's
so much trouble that you can you can
barely stand it and and you see that
because people you know people get
depressed and they commit suicide and
the reason they do that is because they
think not being is better than being and
that's quite the decision you know so
and and it's not that uncommon among
people who are depressed and so it's
it's a it's a very it's a very important
thing to consider and it and it isn't
just a matter of depression and suicide
that's bad enough but you know if you're
unhappy because your suffering has
pushed you past the point of your
ability to cope then there's all sorts
of other things that can happen to you
that aren't directed towards you you can
become cynical and you can become bitter
and you can become cruel and you can
become narcissistic and deceitful and
arrogant and and it's like everything's
for you and then you're out for Revenge
that's a nice one I don't know against
who but maybe everyone maybe even
including you because you're not happy
about the rule you've played in
generating your own misery I mean
there's a lot of Darkness underneath the
suffering and so and and that's that's
an ever-present existential danger for
human beings you know we're aware of the
future we're aware of our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us truly unique
truly conscious in a way that no other
creature is and capable of things that
no other creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load were the only creatures
that have to always contend with the
fact that we're finite and that everyone
we know is in the same position that
allied with the suffering and so that's
there all the time and and you know even
even in in the brightest moments in some
sense you know in in Renaissance
paintings in still lives they used to
put a Memento momento Mori often in the
in the still life like a skull somewhere
in the corner or sometimes sometimes in
in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see see the skull if you
were standing like right beside the
painting instead of dead on but the idea
was to always remember you know that
everything that exists is Tainted or
touched with the with the with the with
it with the taint of mortality and you
know that's rough but there's some
useful things in it it keeps you awake
and it keeps you focused if you're
careful but it also does indicate to you
if you think about it the necessity of
having a meaning in your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as I'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's it's bad enough to have
something bad happen to you and it's
likely that that'll happen but it's even
worse for you to do it to yourself and
to know that you did it that's rough and
it's also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the default position and I
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and I've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very vicious turn into the
darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make everything in the world suffer
for the outrage of its existence man I
mean that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
States take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life overwhelms them and and they turn
and they turn in a very bad Direction
and then they make everything that's
already bad way worse and we're very
very inventive at such things and so
that's not good unless that's the path
you want that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning I don't
know how many of you have read
dostoevsky's crime and punishment but I
would highly recommend that in crime and
punishment the protagonist commits the
perfect murder and he has his reason is
for it and many reasons because
Dostoyevsky didn't mess around when he
wanted to give someone reasons he gave
them reasons and raskolnikov that main
character had reasons for murder and
then he commenced his murder and he gets
away with it
but things don't go well for a skolnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the riskalnikov that you were
before you committed the murder
is not the same as the riskolnikov as
you are after you've committed the
murder and there's a dividing line there
that you don't
it's like the red pill I guess right
it's like it that's the Matrix correct
the red pill
and
once there's certain actions once you
take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and risk golnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so it's it's a great book it's truly
a great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you human consciousness is that
faculty that confronts potential itself
I think there's good neurological
evidence for this by the way for those
of you who are scientifically minded
because uh we build
circuits within us for habitual action
that we've practiced many times that
seem to run in a very deterministic
fashion and we are a strange combination
of deterministic and non-deterministic
as far as I can tell but what our
Consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered and those things that we
have not yet encountered seem to me to
be those things that have not yet been
brought into being and so you could say
that what our Consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our Consciousness is for the
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and and really that that's what
our Consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be you have some
apprehension about what role your
choices might make in transforming that
potential into one form of actuality or
another I mean you certainly know that
there are Dreadful mistakes that you
might be very tempted to make that would
produce all manner of hell around you
and still be tempted to do it it seems
like it's sitting there right in front
of you as a possibility you also know
that you know you could haul yourself up
out of bed and attend to your duties and
do the sorts of things that you're
supposed to and said a few things right
that day and that week and that likely
things would at least not be worth and
they would probably be better and I I
believe that I do believe that I don't
understand how this can be the case I
don't understand how it is that
Consciousness Consciousness can function
in that way because I think to
understand that we would have to
understand what it means for the future
to be only potential rather than
actuality and who the hell understands
that I mean no one and then we'd have to
understand how it is that our conscious
choices and our conscious ethical
choices transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
but we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again I
would say that's a very deep idea I
think it's a I think it's I think it's
the most true idea I know it's very
emphasize that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in Genesis or in
Genesis with its strange insistence that
you know God is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image is to act in
relationship to the potential that
confronts you with truth and with
courage with careful articulation that's
the logos and that if you do that then
what you bring forth is is good Genesis
one of the things God has Adam do first
so God makes the World by speaking okay
so that's the first thing to think about
you're supposed to think like in a
sophisticated way about this that the
idea is that there's some integral
relationship between communication and
the structure of being
it's part of the role that Consciousness
plays in the world whatever that role is
language
takes the chaos and makes it into things
and so
God has Adam name all the animals
they're not even really real until they
have names
now they're more implicit that's another
you know here's a here's an example
let's say that
you're having a rough patch in your
relationship
and you don't know why it's unnameable
is it real well yeah it's manifesting
itself in a like a physiological
discomfort
then you talk about it and you name it
it's like it goes from this blurry thing
that's kind of potential it goes snap
and then it's this thing right and then
that's a horrible thing it's like a
little poisonous thing but it's not a
whole foggy cloud of potential poison
it's like this little sharp poison thing
then you think okay
it's real it's a little monster but it's
not it's little at least and now
probably we can do something about it if
we can admit to it so it's this
Precision that's specified you've got to
name them first absolutely because the
unnamable is far more terrifying than
the nameable
you see that in there was this great
Blair Witch Project terrifying movie
yeah well it's unnamed there's nothing
terrible happens in that movie it's all
the unnamable it's like what's going on
what's going on what's going on and no
matter how terrible the actuality is
it's rarely as terrible as your
imagination because your imagination
like it's an old thing it's seen a lot
of terrible things in the history of
life like it can put Monsters Everywhere
and so it's almost always better
it might be better without exception to
name the thing no matter how terrible it
is and if you can't name it what that
means is that you're you're telling
yourself that you're so terrified that
you can't bring your attention to bear
on it and that makes you you're the
loser instantly if it's so terrifying
that you cannot face it it's what my
wife is a massage therapist and she's
very physiologically aware and so she's
also helped me with this sort of thing
but we watch people on the streets all
the time and people in general now have
very poor posture very bad for them
that's got to be phone related too right
well yeah I think that's part of it but
I also think it's something our culture
doesn't attend to like you kind of have
to remind your kids to stand up you know
it takes a certain amount of conscious
effort but yeah in that chapter I talk a
lot about lobsters which I'm I'm kind of
I kind of have an affinity for lobsters
and because they well the the short
story is that when a lobster loses a
fight
because they're fighting all the time
for dominance let's say in their
hierarchies he kind of crunches down so
he looks smaller when he wins the fight
he stretches out looks bigger and so
he's signaling to other lobsters the
tally of his victories let's say so if a
lobster has won a fight he's more likely
to win the next fight then you would
calculate from having a tally of all his
previous defeats and victories and if he
loses a fight then he's more likely to
lose the next fight so that's that that
Matthew principle at work okay so you
think well so what so what does that
have to do with anything it's like okay
here part of the kicker is
well the lobster runs on serotonin
neurochemical
and if the lobster loses the serotonin
levels go down and if he wins the
serotonin levels go up and when the
serotonin levels go up he stretches out
and he's a confident Lobster and one of
the consequences of that is if a lobster
loses a battle and you give him the
equivalent of antidepressants
then he stretches out he'll go fight
again so antidepressants work on
lobsters right and you think well who
cares it's like no no no you don't get
it
we diverged from lobsters from an
evolutionary perspective 350 million
years ago and it's the same circuit it's
absolutely unbelievable and that shows
you how deep inside you how basic how
primordial that circuit is in you that's
sizing other people up and looking at
where they fit in the hierarchy with
human society it's more like hierarchies
of competence than dominance per se but
and like if you're
serotonin levels fall
you get depressed you crunch forward and
and the whole everything around you
turns cloudy and black and and then
you're inviting more oppression right
and so you get into this bad Loop you
know and so it's really important to if
you're trying to get your act together
it's really important to stretch
yourself out and and sit up properly
because it's it's part of the
psychophysiological loop that can start
you on the upward curve and so it's a
really important thing to take note of
and like if you've been bullied
say when you were a kid maybe you've
moved and so it's sort of irrelevant
you're still carrying that with you in
the in the shoulders and then you can't
breathe properly and your voice isn't
right and and you invite more bullying
because the Predator types are always
looking for people who
who look like they can be intimidated
and who will make a nice fuss if they
are you know like a nice gratifying
they'll make nice gratifying sounds of
suffering you are where you are right
now in your life in your business
because of you because of your mindset
your actions your habits your beliefs
your where you're at because of you it's
nobody else's fault you're not further
behind you're not you're not lower than
you used to be you're not further behind
on your goals but you're also not
further ahead you're not where you want
to be and it's because of you it's not
it's not the government's fault it's not
the tax tax policy fault it's not your
country's fault it's not your parents
fault your education's fault it's your
friend's fault it's none of those things
it's you it's you it's you it's you it's
you it's you it's you it's you it's you
and listen at the beginning that sounds
like a lot of
tough medicine it's like well it's not
my fault I mean sure it's my fault but
come on look at what happened covet
happened you know all this other stuff
happened and it's easy to to put the
blame on something else
but when you can actually realize that
you are where you are because of you
it's it's not just a tough love it's
actually the most empowering thing of
all time
because when you take the responsibility
it doesn't mean it's your fault it
doesn't mean that you can change
anything that you've done in the past
but it's your responsibility
to get to a different place it's not
about assigning blame
it's about taking responsibility which
is the ability to respond right
responsibility equals the ability to
respond do you have an ability to
respond yes when always
cope it happened great do you have an
ability to respond yes what are you
doing about it and while most people are
upset and complaining and waiting for
the government to do something
you're off responding you're off making
a change you're off making a difference
making a pivot making new things happen
that's what separates successful people
from everybody else and I want that for
you
so it recognizes that okay here's here
I'm stuck here this is where I am right
now I don't want to stay stuck here
I want to change I want to grow I've got
a big mission that I have to go off and
accomplish how do you do that you change
your mindset you change your beliefs do
you change your habits and it starts
with you accepting responsibility for
where you're at
I've got you know my main channel three
million subscribers I'm not a 10. I'm
not a one I'm not at I'm not at 50
subscribers
and so the point is then beat ourselves
up I'm I'm grateful for everything that
I've done I'll own the fact that hey I I
got us to building an organization a
team a structure uh making 10 000 videos
to now you know I've got three million
subscribers amazing great pat on the
back and I'm not a 10. I'm not a 10
because I need to get better the videos
need to get better the team needs to get
better the strategy needs to get better
the Productions to get better everything
needs to get better for me to get to
where I want to go
it's easy for me to say well nobody's
done that inside of thought leadership
nobody's done it before
nobody's nobody has a 10 million
subscriber Channel inside of thought
leadership nobody I could say people
don't care what education that much I
could say well I don't have as many
resources as
somebody who's further ahead or part of
some giant Corporation I don't I don't
have as many resources I could say well
I'm introverted and shy and you know and
so I can't I can't be great yeah there's
a there's a ceiling to how good I can be
right and these are the kinds of
thinking that are fear-based that keep
you small because we don't want to
accept the responsibility because the
responsibility feels like blame and
that's where you have to separate it
it's not about blame it's not saying
that you suck it's not saying you should
have done something different it's not
beating ourselves up
it's the ability to respond
I'm not trying to blame anything for
where I'm at and I hope you're not
blaming yourself or anybody around you
for where you're at
but it's taking on the ability to say
you know what I I don't want to end up
in the same spot if I'm a year from now
and I'm still at X
right then I'm gonna be upset
because I I can change
you can change so how do we do it how do
we start to develop that that sense of
responsibility how do we start to
actually take the action we need to take
action on a couple things one
change your environment
if you're surrounded by people by
thinking where it's constantly
complaining especially blaming like
watch out for people who blame
watch out for people to say wow was it's
that person's fault it's their fault
it's it's this person's fault it's their
fault over there I never accepted any
responsibility or they're just
constantly trying to blame other people
right watch out for those people don't
be infected by their cancer that's a
cancer that person is never going to be
happy you need to really dramatically
reduce the amount of times that you're
spending with those kinds of people and
then inject it with more of the
positivity more of the optimism more of
the responsibility whatever you want
more of in your life if it's accepting
responsibility surround yourself with
the people who are doing it surround
yourself with the people who have that
mindset either in in person or through
videos like this
you know you I may never meet you but
you can learn from this I you may never
meet Jordan Peterson but you can learn
from this video right you can learn from
their content their videos their books
their podcasts so it's an immediate
change in your environment because you
are a product of your environment your
environment
impacts your subconscious
you're not even consciously knowing but
if you're around people who are blaming
other people all the time you're gonna
just by default start to blame other
people start to complain a lot of the
time
you'll have to consciously make the
shift to say I don't want to be this
person why am I complaining so much why
am I so negative and nasty why am I
blaming other people so much look at
your environment
that's the reason why
so we're cutting out or restricting
access to the people who are in that
blaming complaining mode and we're
injecting positivity in through humans
through videos books podcasts Etc right
step number one change your environment
step number two
is recognize the situation for what it
is no worse than it is
but no better than it is
what is the situation right now so if
I'm looking at my my main YouTube
channel and I'm trying to grow it okay
where am I at I'm at three million
subscribers great it's no worse than it
is it's not like oh I suck and I don't
know what to do and I'm not grateful for
anything that we've built it's looking
at what do I have I've I've got a
channel I've got some amazing you know
people in the community I've got an
amazing team of people who help me
it's great for where I'm at
it's no worse than it is we tend to beat
ourselves up and feel like we're further
behind but it's also no better than it
is it's not where I want to be yet and
we're still not good enough at anything
we're not good enough at production that
thumbnails the titles and editing at me
being on camera like we're not good at
we're not good enough at any of this
stuff none of it right this is where we
need to be so you're changing your
environment step number one to have a
more optimistic more positive more
energetic more happy environment around
this two we're then looking at the
situation for what is the truth of it no
worse than it is
but no better than it is when it's worse
we pound on ourselves and tell ourselves
we suck when is better we feel like we
don't have to change because everything
is great right so no worse than it is no
better and then three is what are your
actual steps what are you gonna do
what's the plan of action
when you can look at the truth of the
situation what needs to actually improve
how do you actually start making
progress towards your goals what are the
habits for teens mindset belief shifts
that you need to make
on a daily basis like what does today
now look like not just in in theory of I
need to believe in myself more awesome
yes I love it that's changing your
environment how does that apply to today
like what are you going to do today
that's different than what you did
yesterday what are you gonna do this
week that's different than what you did
last week what's the new plan
what's the new plan that you're going to
execute on every single day to move
closer to actually accomplishing your
goals
and if you can follow that process you
can follow those steps and it's a it's a
continuous loop right you're never done
on any of it
you're never done you're always trying
to improve your environment
always you're always trying to prove in
your environment you're always trying to
see the world for what it is right now
see your situation for what it is right
now I know you're always trying to
create a plan to then actually execute
to help you get closer to your goals
always and and that's not hopefully
stressful to you because you always want
to be growing you always want to be
learning you always want to be proven
the day the progress stops the day you
stop liking your life if there was no
progress no growth no change you
wouldn't like your life you'd be bored
go get a job that's that's what most
people do and most people don't like
their life because they're in a really
really boring job right so you you have
these steps on Loop on repeat and that's
how you start getting closer to becoming
the person you want to be and achieving
the goals that you want
at the start of all this though it's
still the accepting responsibility
responsibility does not equal blame
you are where you are because of you
because of the choices that you made
because of the beliefs that you have
because the actions that you have taken
you are where you are because of those
actions and that's gotten you so far
[Music]
and if you want to change you want to
grow you want to improve you want to hit
your mission you want to get closer to
hitting your goals
you now have to take responsibility for
the person you need to become to
actually make those dreams a reality
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to become the person you wanted to
be with Jordan Peterson check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there don't make a plan that is what
you should do make a plan that outlines
a future so that you can sit back and
say look if I had that future then all
the horrible things that are going to
happen to me are going to be worthwhile
that's what you want